well they waited until friday to do it
but the buy administration has finally
released a version of the documents they
used to justify the police state raid on
donald trump's home two weeks ago
unfortunately it's heavily redacted in a
moment we'll tell you what is in that
warrant and what they seem to be hiding
here's a clue a lot
but first good evening and welcome to
tucker carlstein happy friday every year
since 1970s the state department has
published a document called world
military expenditures and arms transfers
you probably haven't read it but it is
interesting it's a detailed accounting
of global arms sales what weapons were
sold and where they wound up after they
were
the us government published this report
in the interest of transparency and then
continued to publish it through multiple
politically charged scandals and
conflicts that would include through
iran contra two separate wars in iraq
and all 20 years that we occupied
afghanistan
a report like this would be especially
useful to have right now may be critical
to have as the bite administration sends
billions in high-tech military equipment
every month to corrupt oligarchs in
eastern europe where are all of those
weapons systems going we should know the
answer to that but we don't know because
this year for the very first time in
half a century the bite administration
has stopped releasing that information
they never explained why they stopped
they just stopped and no one pushed them
now you'd think this would be a scandal
if there's one thing the news media
exists to do it's to fight for the
release of relevant government records
because in a democracy you have a right
to know what is being done in your name
but not anymore that information is
classified mr citizen
so you don't get to find out
where those billions of dollars of
weapons that you're paying for are going
who's getting them what are they doing
with them you don't get to know
you don't get to learn about anything
about ashley biden sharing with her
father you can get arrested for that you
don't get to know how many fbi assets
were in the crowd on january 6th and
what they were doing as we just noted
you don't get to read the affidavit
justifying the fbi's indefensible rate
on the home of joe biden's primary
political opponent in fact you don't
even get to know why you're not allowed
to know
because that information has been
redacted too what do you a russian agent
stop asking
didn't used to be this way at all it's
unrecognizable
a lot has changed in a very short time
so it turns out looking back 18 months
the 2020 election was the most
consequential election of our lifetimes
you assumed joe biden was incapacitated
and couldn't change much well true he is
incapacitated but the people behind him
most definitely are not
they are more ideological and more
aggressive than ever
now it turns out among those people
is our largest and most heavily armed
federal law enforcement agency that
would be the fbi the fbi is not allowed
to insert itself into domestic politics
that would violate the u.s constitution
it is completely illegal
but for several years it has become
increasingly clear that is exactly what
the fbi is doing actively working on
behalf of the democratic party
mocking the rule of law subverting our
democracy from within far more
effectively than any foreign government
ever could
if that sounds like an overheated claim
and it definitely does sound like an
overheated claim unfortunately you
should know it's entirely true we know
that for a fact
here's how we know and we learned it
yesterday
weeks before the 2020 election the fbi
pressured social media companies to kill
the story of hunter biden's laptop
why because that was a story that might
have prevented joe biden from becoming
president
that happened
and we know this not because the new
york times investigated it they didn't
bother they didn't bring you a special
report in yesterday's paper giving you
the details the new york times would
never do that even if they knew it to be
true and they may
no
we know this instead because mark
zuckerberg of facebook blithely admitted
it almost parenthetically during an
interview with joe rogan watch this
there was a lot of attention on twitter
during the election because of the
hunter biden laptop story the new year
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than twitter
um i mean basically the background here
is the fbi i think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be some kind of dump of of um
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant
oh so zuckerberg just to be clear you
just saw it but let's just unwind what
we saw zuckerberg was asked why did you
censor
the story about hunter biden's laptop
and he said some folks from the fbi came
to us and indicated there was about to
be a dump
of russian propaganda now there's some
rereading of history going on in which
some are claiming some at facebook are
claiming actually
that the visit from the fbi had nothing
to do with the hunter button laptop but
the answer you just saw was in response
to a question about the laptop and the
censorship of it and the answer was
russian propaganda russian
disinformation neither of those terms
has an agreed upon meaning they don't
actually mean anything what's russian
propaganda is it true that should be the
only question that any news or
information company including facebook
ever ask is it true
truth is the defense
no it's russian propaganda again a term
without a meaning
so we wanted to know more we reached out
to mark zuckerberg after that interview
and he responded to us to his credit
zuckerberg confirmed that the fbi didn't
put any of these warnings about russian
disinformation propaganda in writing
oh well of course they didn't
nothing in writing
and that makes sense if you're the fbi
you wouldn't want to put that in writing
because you were of course lying at the
moment the fbi was warning facebook
about a propaganda dump that obviously
would include hundred biden's laptop
they had hunter biden's laptop in their
possession
so they knew perfectly well it was
authentic because anyone who looks at it
does we have looked at it and it's
instantly obvious this is real and of
course we now know conclusively it is
real
so that laptop was not censored because
it was propaganda whatever that means by
the way the fbi should never be in the
information control business
anyway it was censored because it might
hurt joe biden and the fbi
is the government agency
that pushed for it to be censored
has that ever happened in the united
states ever
that is the definition of police state
behavior a government agency
independently decides it's going to
determine the outcome
of a supposedly democratic election
so why is it nearly two years
until we learn this
well it turns out facebook is a very
political place the founder of facebook
mark zuckerberg paid hundreds of
millions of dollars to affect the
outcome of the election famously we've
reported on that and then of course
there were democratic party operatives
working within facebook
so on october 14th the facebook
communications official and former
democratic party operative called andy
stone claimed that facebook was
censoring this story because of
facebook's quote standard process to
reduce the spread of misinformation
whatever that means but that was their
initial explanation it wasn't until late
october that mark zuckerberg the ceo of
the company publicly mentioned the fbi's
involvement for the first time and
here's what he said we relied heavily on
the fbi's intelligence and alerts both
through their public testimony and
private briefings that they gave us he
testified to that
but at the time mark zuckerberg didn't
mention anything but the fbi warning
facebook about quote russian propaganda
specifically
why didn't he say anything that's odd
because in october 2020
right before the election weeks before a
presidential election every media outlet
in the country and then candidate joe
biden himself were using the very same
line
it's russian misinformation it's
propaganda and not surprisingly or
coincidentally dozens of quote former
intelligence officials were saying the
same thing
we can't play this enough here it is
when you look at this computer uh store
owner in delaware who allegedly received
hunter biden's laptop that is more in
line with that when you think about
somebody who's a useful idiot that's
kind of the entry point that is kind of
again a classic indicator of the
potential uh
presence of disinformation right wing
media has been focused on hunter biden
this laptop that intelligence officials
have warned is likely russian
disinformation law enforcement is
actively investigating whether the
alleged hunter biden emails are linked
to any foreign intel ops the story is
preposterous so we're supposed to
believe that hunter biden and a drunken
super dropped off his laptop and i guess
apparently q and on repair office
so those are just shills who will say
whatever they're told to say of course
no sober person would take them
seriously and we missed the bigger story
too we'll admit that at the time we
imagined that this lie that the laptop
was russian misinformation was being
pushed almost exclusively by democratic
partisans
but that's not true it was much worse
and much more threatening to our
democracy in fact utterly corrosive of
our democracy than that again our media
attributed these claims to former intel
officials who wrote a letter about
russian disinformation but no it wasn't
just former intel officials spreading
that lie
it was members of the u.s government
federal bureaucrats people who work for
federal agencies senior fbi leaders who
are still at the fbi they lied and they
knew they were lying and they never took
steps to validate this claim that it was
russian propaganda or russian
disinformation
on this show in october of 2020 we
interviewed one of hunter biden's
business partners a man called tony
bobolinski and he verified the
authenticity
of that laptop he had first-hand
information he had texts and emails that
were on his phone and also on the laptop
so we reached out to tony bobby galinsky
last night
and we asked him a very simple question
did anyone from the fbi ever call you or
your lawyer
to find out since your name was all over
the laptop
if those texts and emails were real if
they wanted to know if this was russian
disinformation they would of course call
you
but not one of them ever did
they knew it wasn't russian
disinformation they knew it wasn't
propagating they knew it was completely
real and they lied about it
here's what babalinski told us in
october of 2020.
on may 13th that email was sent from
james gillier to me
i didn't generate that email james
gilliard generated that email and in
that email james gillier goes through
intimate detail
of what each individual's requests were
from a compensation perspective and how
the equity in the enterprise would be
divvied up
very important may 13th that email was
generated by somebody else to me
in that email there's a statement where
they go through the equity jim biden is
referenced as you know ten percent
doesn't say binding it says jim and then
it has ten percent for the big guy held
by h
i a thousand percent sit here and know
that the big guy is referencing joe
biden um
it's that's crystal clear to me because
i lived it i met with a former vice
president in person
multiple times and i had been meeting
and talking with hunter biden and jim
biden and rob walker and james killier
so to note the obvious that's not some
cable news mouth breather who's giving
his stupid partisan opinion about hunter
biden's laptop that's hunter biden's
former business partner who can prove he
was hunter biden's former business
partner no in disputes he was hunter
biden's former business partner his name
his emails or texts are all over the
laptop
and yet somehow the fbi the agency that
sent a dozen agents to investigate a
rope in a nascar garage the agency that
used hundreds of agents to hunt down
grandmothers from the election justice
protest on january 6 that same agency
couldn't spare a single agent to make a
telephone call to tony bobelinski to
ask questions about the laptop you claim
it's propaganda it's misinformation why
don't you call the guy who's on it and
ask him
they didn't bother
this is what the fbi has become
an agency that seeks to exert control
over the information that you read in
the media
what is this well it's terrifying
and again this isn't speculation we just
had it confirmed in public yesterday
these are people whose main goal is to
ensure that they never lose power in
washington interfering with our
elections not simply by hiding
information
resorting to force because they know
they can get away with it
joe biden's chief political opponent
right now biden says he's going to run
again trump's indicated he's running it
would be donald trump
and so they're targeting them is anyone
noticing this
john paul mcizek the computer repair
shop owner who first obtained the laptop
says an fbi agent threatened him
so he wouldn't go public with the laptop
in case you've forgotten watch
the fbi
met with me at my home
and asked me about my concerns i voiced
my concerns
and
they
i then shifted and said hey can can i
just want this out of my shop at this
point just get it out of my shop and
give me a phone number i can call should
somebody come looking for it or wants to
harass me about it and they're like yeah
we can't do that when they showed up
instead of bringing a tech guy with them
they brought a subpoena
they're like yeah we're just gonna take
everything i was a bit uncomfortable a
little nervous but then excited at the
same time so i kind of cracked a joke i
said
don't worry lads when i when i write the
book i'll leave your names out of this
that's when agent mike turned around and
said oh it's in our experience nobody
nothing ever happens to people that talk
about these things
yeah
so in a free country
no one who obeys the law is afraid of
law enforcement that's true
no one should ever be afraid of the fbi
except people who know full well they've
committed federal crimes period but in
this country let's be honest everybody's
afraid of the fbi because you know
exactly what happens to you if you
tweak the nose of the fbi
or if you know annoy joe biden you get
raided you get hauled into the street in
leg irons you get banned on social media
as jin saki said for the white house
podium last year quote we're flagging
problematic posts for facebook
oh so that's the white house
same administration which oversees the
fbi
telling social media companies who's
allowed to speak it happened alex
berenson it happened to donald trump now
we know what happened to the new york
post and the people running the fbi
people who did that are still there
this is a huge problem this cannot be
ignored any longer
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight